each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so I'm going to be
talking today about concurrent objects
how to design and imp them but before I
talk about how to do that I want need to
talk about what a concurrent object is
so I'm going to be
talking a little bit in a theoretical
vein to begin with this isn't theory for
the sake of doing Theory although of
course there's nothing wrong with doing
that this is theory in order that we can
understand and attack practical problems
in a more systematic
way now I'm going to start out by
telling you a lot of things that may
seem obvious to many of you uh the
reason is probably best captured by a
story about uh Norbert vener who was a
famous uh computer scientist before the
word was invented in the early part of
the 20th century at MIT and there's a
story that he was teaching a uh course
on complex analysis and he writes
something down and he says and the
following property is obvious then he
stops and he stares at his shoes for a
few minutes then without a word he goes
out into the Hall Paces back and forth
for 45 minutes
walks back in turns to the class and
says it is obvious and
continues so what I want to do is I want
to look at things that may seem obvious
I want to raise doubts in your mind
about whether they are as obvious as
they look and in the end I hope to
resolve this so that you uh feel the
same confidence uh that you originally
felt but this time with a better
foundation so we're interested in a um
model of concurrent computation where we
have a collection of threads or
processes which I'll represent as little
uh processor uh
chips and they share a a memory and
inside the memory are objects and our
notion of an object is pretty much the
same as you would get in uh C uh Java
C++ it's a class that provides methods
and uh
fields and here the real problem that I
want to address is uh well what is a
concurrent object how do we describe a
concurrent object how do I say what I
mean when I talk about a concurrent Q or
concurrent stack or something like that
how do we go about and Implement them
and how do we tell whether we've
implemented it correctly that is how do
we know whether our implementation and
our description
match and the these are the basic
questions that uh need to be understood
before we can build a really effective
concurrent programs now in this lecture
I'm not going to talk about
implementation I'll talk about that in
the next lectures so today I'm going to
uh restrict attention to how we describe
the behavior of of concurrent objects
and how we check that our description is
correct so
um to pick an example imagine that we
have a
fq so fifq uh consists of a collection
of objects uh we have here we have a
thread that's about to enq something and
we write that as saying Q the name of
the object the name of the method uh
followed by arguments and of course Q's
have
uh they have NQ operations and DQ
operations here we
go there DQ returns an object from from
the que and even though this is very
simple uh data structure we'll use that
for many of our
examples so let's build a concurrent Q
in the simplest possible
way uh we'll uh create a circular
buffer uh we'll put a lock on it to a
protect it uh I'll have a pointer to the
head of the queue and a pointer to the
tail of the que so this is something uh
I'm sure you've all seen uh before in
earlier
classes so the fields are protected by a
single shared lock uh we can rep this is
how the code looks in Java uh don't be
alarmed when I show you a code because I
don't expect you to read it and
understand it all at once I merely want
to highlight uh what the pictures look
like when you translate it into code the
details are not so important but here uh
we have the head and the tail
pointer head and tail pointer an array
of items uh and and the
lock and initially the queue is empty
the head points to the
tail uh this is how you would uh
initialize it in U in Java
uh if I want to DQ
something uh what I'll do is I'll
acquire the lock so the Red Thread
acquires a lock which will indicate by
turning the lock red uh the purple
thread comes along and it wants to enue
something but it's locked out so it
can't do
anything uh what happens in the code is
that uh the uh DQ method uh the first
thing it does is it uh calls a lock it
acquires a lock this call blocks until
the lock is are
granted then uh the Q the um thread
checks to see that there's that the Q is
non
empty so it compares the head and tail
pointer and checks to make sure that
they're not the same if they are empty
we'll throw an exception you could do
something else if you wanted
to uh then once we've checked that there
is something to
DQ then uh you go ahead and you move the
ahead and consume the item
so uh here we uh read the item we
increment the head and then when we're
finished we return the
result and before we actually return the
result we have to release the lock so
that the purple thread which has been
patiently waiting all this time can uh
go in and perform its its
operation so then we uh release the lock
the purple thread that can uh can go
on uh here um when I teach the course we
I also we also give lots of programming
exercises so we emphasize little details
like uh you should always unlock your
locks in a final e block but um I won't
dwell on that uh that
here
and after going through all these
details uh belaboring sort of the
obvious way to implement this how do we
know that this is the correct
5q and the answer is well it's got to be
correct because sequential the
sequential code is pretty clearly
correct and we have a lock so that each
of the threads whatever else they do in
parallel when they access this uh Q they
go one at a
time and because these operations happen
one at a time it's pretty clear what uh
first in first out
means because there is basically no
concurrency inside the queue uh we know
which item went in we know the order in
which the items went in we know the
order in which they came out it's easy
to check that it's first in or first out
and there are no philosophical problems
with defining what f means for this kind
of Cu and that's because we do
everything sequentially we have a
lock okay but now let's uh do the same
thing I'm going to tell you how to build
a 5old q without
locks uh this is a very specialized
queue it has only two threads one thread
only does nqs and one thread only does
dqs and and uh we're going to um take a
brief look at that implementation and
while I'm going through the details what
you should be thinking about are not the
details but what does it mean for
something like this to be a fifo q when
operations can overlap and how could you
possibly tell whether this
implementation is
correct so here we have the same
structure as before except we don't have
a
lock
and what happens when the uh we have an
ncer and a dcer come along and uh one of
them wants to DQ from the que and one of
them wants to NQ from the
Q and so what we're going to do is
because there's no
lock they're going to run simultaneously
so the Red Thread is going to read the
value at the head of the que which is
X uh the uh purple thread is going to um
store Z
in the first empty location pointed to
by the
tail and these operations happen at
exactly the same
time and then each one uh modifies the
head and the tail
pointer and both of these operations
happened at the same
time and so the question uh you want to
ask is in intuitively in a very informal
sense does this look like a 5q at
you if uh you hired a consultant
uh for um you know several millions of
Rupees to design a 5q for you and they
produce this uh would you uh uh call the
police and have them arrested for fraud
or would you pay
them so um to make clear what we need so
this is uh the ner uh stores the item in
the uh array increments the tail uh
pointer uh the dcer uh you know does the
same um thing only in the opposite
order and the real question here is how
do we know this is correct how do we
Define what we mean when we say fifo CU
because fifo in its nature talks about
ordering things you know first in uh
first out Stacks are the same way first
in last out but what does it mean to be
first or last in a an environment where
things can happen
simultaneously where there is no obvious
order so this is what I
when I said I'm going to start out by
telling you something that seems obvious
and then raise questions about uh what
it really
means so um again this is almost a
philosophical question what is a
concurrent a CU when uh the definition
of AQ talks about order events that
happen that are ordered but when the
implementation allows things to happen
simultaneously so we need a way to
specify what we mean by concurrent Q we
need a way to prove that a particular
algorithm implement ments a concurrent
q and the place to start is to talk
about object
specifications you know what when we
describe a 5q how do we tell people what
it means when we when we Describe a key
Value Store when we describe a hashtable
any of the common data types we need a
way of specifying how they
behave now um there are two things here
there are safety properties where we
guarantee that nothing bad happens
uh here we safety property says that the
uh traffic lights do not turn green in
all
directions not that that would matter
much in a Bangalore but you know
liveness says that eventually the light
will turn
green
so we'll begin with uh correctness
properties so um this is all quite a
standard for sequential objects you know
the kind that you see in your beginning
operating system class we say well an
object has a state the state of a q is
the sequence of items that it happens uh
usually it's implemented by a set of
fields uh each object also provides a
set of methods which are the only way to
manipulate the object state so given a
5q you can enq things and you can DQ
things and maybe you can do a few other
things like ask about its size but you
can't do arbitrary things to it the
language doesn't allow you to reach in
and do arbitrary modifications in at
least in most
languages and a sequential
specifications usually have the
following form uh they say well if a
particular precondition is true that is
if the object is in a particular State
then if you apply a a particular
operation there will be post condition
which says this is the state of the
object after you're
finished now this is true of formal
specifications but is also true of
informal
specifications if you go to the uh C web
page and look up uh their libraries uh
all of the specifications in one form or
another have this this basic form says
you know you call uh DQ and if the que
is not empty it'll give you back the
first item and it will remove
it uh if it's empty then it will give
you null or it'll throw an exception or
it will block or something like
that so precondition says if you're in
this state before you call the method
then you get back a particular value and
you leave the object in in a new
state and again this is something that
is so familiar to us that we probably
don't think about it very much or about
the
implications of uh these definitions so
for example here we have pre- and post
conditions for deqing something if the
queue is nonempty you get back the first
item and uh the first item is removed
uh if the que is empty then in our case
we throw an empty
exception and the Q state is
unchanged so
um this is such a again such a common
everyday form of specification that we
don't realize how wonderful it is how
useful it is to be able to specify
things in this way so for example we
don't need to talk about how NQ and DQ
interact explicitly because the way they
interact is completely captured by the
post conditions so I know what happens
if I do an NQ followed by a DQ and I
know what happens if I do a DQ followed
by an NQ because I can look at the post
condition of one operation and the
precondition of the other and they fit
together
nicely uh this means that the size of
the documentation is linear in the
number of
methods I can describe each method in
isolation I don't need to talk about how
it interacts with anything else
if I want to add a new method you know
if I want to add a size method I can do
that and express it entirely in terms of
pre- and post conditions I don't need to
talk about how size interacts with NQ or
DQ because the way that the
specification is encoded uh uh doesn't
um doesn't require
that so now question is what happens
when we go to
concurrent uh
specifications so so now we have a fifo
q that can be accessed concurrently by
multiple uh
threads uh we have a hash table that can
be mod accessed by multiple threads we
have an operating system that can be
accessed by multiple threads how do we
specify
that can we do this in the same way that
we specify a sequential
objects so uh let's do a little bit of
physics so the truth is that uh methods
take time
so here we have a arrow of time and at
noon the blue thread uh says enq a
particular
item and then the method call proceeds
for a little
while and then at 1201 it
returns now in this also happens in the
sequential world but we don't
particularly care because nothing else
is going on at the same time but
concurrency breaks a lot of abstractions
that we take completely for granted and
so in the sequential world we can
pretend that method calls are
instantaneous for reasoning about
correctness but we can't do that in the
concurrent
world so the first thing they Chang is
is we have to admit that a um calling a
method is not an an instantaneous event
it's an
interval it's an interval that uh that
takes
time and concurrent methods take
overlapping time
so here we have uh the Red Thread sorry
the blue thread makes a method call and
the green thread makes another method
call that
overlaps so whereas for sequential
specifications uh without any effort at
all we could talk about what happens
when uh one method is called and then
another method is called now we have to
worry about what happens when method
calls
overlap when one of them starts before
another one is finished and we have to
answer questions like what does first in
first out
mean when it's not clear who's
first so in the sequential world we can
add new methods without affecting other
methods but if our methods are going to
overlap with with each other I have to
tell you if your NQ overlaps with the DQ
then this is what could happen and every
time I add a new method I've got to give
you tell you how it how it interacts if
it overlaps with all the other
methods so this means at least the n s
size
specification and I've got to tell what
happens if three operations happen to
overlap with each other so there's only
one rational response to this and that's
uh complete a panic because all of our
nice methodology and structures for
specifying what an object means don't
work
anymore the found ations of the way that
we think about data structures have been
undermined by
concurrency and uh you know the U simply
trying to Define what we mean when we
talk about concurrent objects represents
a uh quite a
challenge so this this is the question
that uh we're going to answer in uh this
talk is what does it mean for concurrent
object to be correct what is a
concurrent fifo Q when fifo when
concurrent
have incompatible
meanings uh and how how do we resolve
the inherent ambiguity in the order in
which operations take
effect so
intuitively in the lock based
implementation we didn't need to worry
about this because all the Q operations
were completely um mutually exclusive
and they did happen one at a time order
and so we can treat them we can use a
sequential
specification uh to talk about
operations that are mutually
exclusive now if we look at the
concurrent executions that
happen uh the NQ and the DQ can overlap
in time if you sit there with a watch
and you uh look at the uh calls and
returns they overlap but we're not
troubled by this
because the what happens in the the ener
acquires the lock it executes the
sequential code and it releases the lock
while this is going on the dcer is
waiting to acquire the lock it finally
acquires the lock and then releases the
lock so although the entire methods May
overlap with each other the important
parts
don't we can in some sense narrow the uh
duration to the important part and that
is and those happen sequentially so the
actual NQ the sequential NQ and the
sequential DQ
in
a an implementation that uses a locks
the order is still
unambiguous and we can say that even
though these operations may have
overlapped they appear to have happened
what they actually did happen in a
sequential
order so this idea that we can take
concurrent overlapping operations and
say well you know you can see that they
overlap but really we can treat them as
if they happened in a one in time order
is our first step out of this conceptual
Amaze of uh deciding what it means for
concurrent objects to um to behave
correctly so the behavior is sequential
even if the um executions are
not
so just about every way that people have
ever proposed of making sense out of
concurrent computation usually boils
down to some way of saying well we have
this concurrent computation but don't
worry it's equivalent to some sequential
computation and uh people fight
religious wars about the exact right way
to do this but this theme of saying uh
concurrent is actually equivalent to
sequential somehow is very common in
this
area so this is the um correctness
condition that uh we're going to um
study in this lecture is called
linearizability the idea here very
informally is that each method call
should appear to take
effect
instantaneously at some point between
when the method is called and when it
returns so that's a very simple
intuitively appealing um definition it
matches our definition for the lock
based uh scheme because you can say well
when you release the lock that's when
your uh operation takes effect but it
also works for implementations that
don't
locks so
um technically uh what we're saying is
that every execution of the object has
this property so it's not so much a
property of an object it's a property of
all the executions of all the behaviors
that the object can
display uh so so when when we get later
on when we talk about some of the formal
definitions we'll keep that in mind but
we'll say that a linearizable object is
one uh who's for which every execution
is um is
linearizable okay so let's look at at an
example so here we have our fifo Q
again uh so I'm going to use the
notation uh this is the object q. NQ and
that's the um
argument and the color will represent
the process ID so here the blue process
nq's
X on Q U on 5q
Q concur C ly the red process or the red
thread and q's
Y and these operations uh overlap each
other and now the blue or the Red Thread
DQ's
X the value that was n QED uh by by the
blue uh
thread and then when that is
finished the blue thread comes along and
DQ's
y now the question question is uh is
this a linearizable
execution does this satisfy our
conditions that the operation must
appear to take effect at some instant
between the start and the end of the
call so let's do a poll how many people
think that this is indeed
linearizable how many are there any
denters
so this is linearizable
because we can we can find an instant
here where the operations happen so the
NQ of X happens here the NQ of Y happens
here uh the DQ of X happens here and the
DQ of Y happens here and you put them in
order and that is a sequential fifo
execution so to show that something's
linearizable you have to find an order
that just justifies
it so the idea here is some Behavior
happens can we justify this Behavior as
a sequential
Behavior Uh so here's a here's another
uh
example so here the blue thread nq's X
DQ's
Y and uh the Red Thread DQ's
y does that loc
linearizable
uh answer is no because we can't find a
way to order them and besides uh nobody
ever inced y to begin
with so there's no way that we can
represent this as a correct sequential
history of a 5 Cube so that's not
linearizable
uh here we have a uh interesting example
so the blue thread nq's X but hasn't
returned
yet it uh went off and to to take a nap
uh the red thread
dqx in an overlapping
operation so should is that a a correct
linearizable execution of a f
Cube how many people would be willing to
accept
this how many people would want their
money back if uh if you got
this so I claim it's perfectly okay
because all that we said was sometime
between the invocation and the response
the execution has to take effect and
here's an order where the NQ actually
took effect but the uh thread was simply
slow to return and here the DQ took
effect at this point and that that
ordering is uh is perfectly
okay yes
oh the pre the um oh so this example
here
so actually there's a
um let's go
back so here we have
um this is uh not uh correct for sever
reasons uh one is that X is NQ and then
Y is DQ but X was never placed in I'm
assuming the Q was empty to begin
with and so and so the value that's
returned is is different from the value
that's
um oh oh right right sorry the
um yes okay now I'm
uh so so
here the the NQ had to happen somewhere
in this
range and the the NQ of Y had to happen
somewhere in this
range but we need to be able find an
order where y was nced
first and we can't do that
because no we can't push the uh Point
beyond the return and we can't pull this
any further so that's the
uh
okay so here here's another um tricky
case so here we have X and Y are inced
concurrently and here X and Y are dced
concurrently and the question is is that
a linearizable behavior is that a a 5q
behavior and the answer is uh yes
because we could order it this
way we could say uh yep uh y was NQ
before X and Y was DQ before X so that's
5o or we could say well in fact X was
dced before Y and X was sorry X was n
cubed before Y and X was dced before
y so not only is this linearizable it's
uh linearizable in two different orders
so the linearization order doesn't have
to be unique it's perfectly okay if
there's more than
one we don't have to just um look at Q's
so here is an example of a read write
variable here the blue thread writes
zero concurrently the Red Thread writes
one the blue thread reads
one the blue thread writes two and then
the Red Thread reads
zero and and the question is is that a
linearizable
execution and you know a read write
variable you're supposed to uh read the
last value that was
written and so so you know this is uh
kind of a puzzle but the way to um to go
through there see through this is to say
well you know the
right
here so so here I read one and I have an
overlapping right so where whenever the
right took place it must have happened
before this line because otherwise the
read wouldn't have returned it but if uh
the right happened here that
means if the right of one happened back
here then the right of two must have
overwritten it because it must have
happened
later so be because of this read we know
we that the right of one must have
happened before this point which means
the right of two must have happened
before this point which means that Reed
could not have seen uh
zero because it would have been
overwritten uh if we change this to a
one it's the same um uh same thing
because a one uh would have been
overwritten by uh by that but here's
something
curious
that if I remove the read and leave
everything else the same then is the
linearizable because since I didn't read
the value one now it's much more
ambiguous about when one happened and in
particular the right of one could have
taken place here after the right of
two so this is an example of something
where not observing what happened can
increase in some sense the level of a of
a concurrency or can increase the
freedom of the implementation to return
return different answers so there are a
number of the counterintuitive things
that can
happen with this kind of
definition okay so
um now another kind of technical Point
here is that uh when we talk
about the linearization point of an
operation is the instant when it takes
effect or the in this may be fictional
but this is the instant when it could
have taken
effect and in order to do this question
is can given a um a particular
implementation can we always point to
one line of code and say this is the
linearization point and the answer is
often we can but not always and there
will be a tricky cases where the
linearization point depends on the
entire execution not on the uh single
operation that we're looking at and
we'll see a few examples of that um
later
on okay so um
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take all those cartoons that I showed
you and tell you how to write them down
in slightly more formal uh uh
notation uh it would be nice if we could
do all our proofs in terms of pictures
and arrows and cartoons but in fact we
have to uh use a more compact notation
in order to U make sense out of things
and so what I'm going to do is
um give you the same definitions I've
given you intuitively in a slightly more
precise uh way uh this will allow us to
prove some properties of linearizability
that might not be
obvious uh which would be difficult to
do with all that we had were
cartoons okay so um the first thing is
when you call a method we're going to
split it into two pieces the invocation
the call and the response so here uh we
have our same notation we have object Q
method NQ value X and what you get back
is a either return value or an
exception and so this is the we'll write
the thread uh over here object method
and uh and
arguments uh for response uh we'll do
the same uh we'll leave the method
implicit just to keep the notation from
getting too uh too crowded
and we you know we treat exceptions uh
in the obvious
way so a
history uh is a um sequence of events
where we inter leave the effects of um
operations so for our purposes a um
method call and a response are
instantaneous
events the method itself consists of two
is an interval because it's the interval
between the call and the response uh a
history is just the sequence of uh
things that happen so we're going to
model the world as a sequence of events
there are other ways to do this you
could do this with automaton in various
ways mathematically they're all the same
and people will argue for hours about
which one is um you know most elegant
and most powerful uh but we're picking
this one because it is the
simplest uh not because it's the uh best
for proving sophisticated theorems
uh so this is a an example you know here
thread a has three events thread B has
three
events we'll say that invocational
response
match if their uh thread names agree and
the object names agree and their um one
follows the other in the in the history
and we'll call this interval between the
invocation and the mat matching response
the method
call uh given a history we like to be
able to project project onto uh objects
to say look at the subis that involves a
particular object or we also like to
project on to threads and say tell me
what happened to thread
B uh we'll say that an invocation is
pending if it has no matching
response so a pending invocation is
inherently
ambiguous because if we see an
invocation and a response we know that
that operation has taken effect by the
end of that history because it's
returned but if you see a pending
invocation then that may or may not have
taken
effect uh sometimes we care about the
history of complete operations and there
all we do is we take all the pending
invocations and we throw them
away and that captures uh all the the
method calls that we know for sure have
happened so in case uh we take the
complete of H that discards uh the
pending
invocation okay so a sequential history
is one uh where there's no
interleaving that is every
um there's no interleaving between
method calls interleaving between
threads is fine so here a um does an NQ
here B does an NQ here B does a DQ and
it's okay to have a final pending
invocation but it has to be
final so a sequential history is
something where there's no
overlapping uh well-formed history is
one where every thread projection is
sequential what we're saying there is
our model of a thread is it's basically
a sequential execution it
makes makes an invocation it waits it
gets back the response it makes another
invocation gets back the response one
could imagine generalizations where you
could concurrently make two invocations
and wait for the responses but uh we're
not going to do that we're going to
capture that by having separate threads
so there are many U minor
generalizations and complications we
could do to this model but we're not
going to do that here because that would
be a distraction from the main point
that we want to
make so here this thread is well formed
because it says that um A and B are both
sequential histories and we're going to
assume that that's all uh all there
is so two threads are equivalent if no
sorry two histories are equivalent if no
thread can tell them apart so here we
have two histories where things are in
slightly different order but if we
project on a then a can't doesn't see
any difference and same for
B okay a sequential specification is
some way of telling whether a single
thread single object history is legal so
when we say 5q we're thinking of a
sequential specification when we say
stack when we say uh hash table we have
in mind particular uh sequential
Behavior that's
acceptable uh again there are many ways
of specifying this you know you can
specify a sets of histories you could
specify it via automata regular
languages all kinds of things uh we
don't care about the det s here all we
care is that there's some way of saying
these are the sets of behaviors that we
consider to be um uh
correct so if we have a history that has
multiple objects then uh we say this
history is correct if projecting on each
individual object is correct exactly the
definition you would
expect so this is a an important idea so
we'll say that one method call precedes
another if it's unambiguous what order
they should take
effect uh that means that they don't
overlap that means that the response of
one appears before the uh uh invocation
of the other so here the green events
form a method call the orange events
form a method call and it's unambiguous
that green must have happened before
orange so this is uh the precedent
order
and notice it's a partial order because
method calls that overlap are unordered
by this that's that's because
um from first principles that we can't
tell what order they take effect
in because they could they could take
effect in either order whereas uh if one
precedes another uh one must uh be
ordered in front of the
other so um given history H and two
method executions that is pairs of
invocations and responses will say that
m0 precedes M1 in h if M if um it if it
satisfies the Precedence definition I
just gave you and that's a partial order
and if H is a sequential history then
it's a total
order so already we're starting to see
that uh what linearizability is is a way
of saying we take this partial
order that is inherent in the
definition and find some way to extend
end it to a total
order and the partial order is the
partial order of of basically the
real-time Behavior if I apply one
operation and then I wait a while and I
apply the other operation they should
take effect in the order that I apply
applied them you're not allowed to
reorder that
much so revisiting the the intuitive
informal definition I gave you with a
slightly uh more formal definition we'll
say history is linearized if we can
extend it to a sequential history by
appending zero or more responses to
pending
invocations that is these are the method
calls that have taken effect but haven't
yet returned so we find some set of
those and we complete them uh we throw
away the rest and we say well G has to
be equivalent to some legal sequential
history where the partial order is a
subset of the total order which is just
a mathematical way of saying that we
have this real-time ordering on
events and we have to respect that and
other than that we have to find a way of
taking all the ambiguous orderings and
uh straightening them out in a way that
gives us a legal sequential
history so this is just a mathematic
mathematical restating of what we were
doing of the puzzles we were doing with
the pictures saying is there some way we
can order these to get a legal
sequential history if there such an
order exists then it's linearizable and
correct if there is no such order order
then this is not a correct uh behavior
of of the
object so uh here's a um revisiting some
of these examples with
um here in history G we have a we have a
b and
c uh here the color represents a um the
thread ID so G says that a has to come
before c and b has to come before c and
that's a partial order and the
serialization that we pick is we're
going to say a comes from before B so
that is we're going to these two could
be ordered in either order but we're
going to order them in this order and if
the result is a legal history then uh
then we're
done so um going back over some of the
pending invocations take effect so we
keep those and we throw away the rest uh
figuring out which ones to pick is uh
you know exponential but in practice
it's not U that's not a
problem another example here we have an
orange event orange method is called but
doesn't return uh NQ if3 here we uh nq4
dq4 and
q6 and we say this is we complete the
pending invocation because we know this
must have taken effect because
uh actually why do we know
that well we complete it and then we
order it uh we discard that
one and then we take those and we or
order them uh in that
way and that
way for was Ned first uh for was dced
first and then a was ened after sorry
three was enced
after and that's an equivalent
sequential
history so again all I'm doing is I'm
writing down in a more precise way the
kinds of intuitive exercises we were
doing earlier
on now here is uh an important
theorem which has uh sweeping practical
implications so what this says is that
linearizability is a composable property
in the sense that if I take a collection
of objects that are individually
linearizable and I put them together in
a system the result remains
linearizable now this might sound
obvious but in fact the other
correctness conditions that people have
proposed as alternatives to
linearizability usually don't satisfy
this and this is a problem because it
says that uh uh if it's not composable
then you can't subcontract your work so
if I want to build a system consisting
of a linearizable uh stack a
linearizable Q and linearizable hash
table then I could take everyone in this
side of the room and and say okay go off
and do the queue I could tell everyone
in the middle to do the stack and
everyone over here to do the hash table
and they could work without ever
communicating with each other and then
when you bring back your results I can
test them individually and guarantee
that they're linearizable I can put them
together into a system and it will be
linearizable without any further um Ado
but as we'll see when I look at when we
look at later examples that uh this is
can't be taken for
granted
so again it's it's a modularity argument
that uh it's important to be able to
prove linearizability of objects and
isolation because we you don't know how
you're going to want to integrate them
into other systems later
on so um for example here here's an
example of um how to reason about a
linearizable implementation so first
we'll look at the a lock based uh
implementation so one way to do this is
to say well the linearization points are
when the locks are
released so if I build any object where
I take sequential code and put a lock
around
it then I can pick as my linearization
point the moment when the locks are
released because that's when its changes
become visible the truth is I could also
pick the point when the lock was
acquired that would also work or any
point in between uh so proving
linearizability for lock based
implementation
is actually pretty uh Ty pretty
simple uh things get a little bit more
exciting when we look at the weit free
implementation the one without locks so
ignore this lock here that's not
supposed to be there uh so this is the
one where we have two threads one an
enqing thread and one a deqing
thread and what happens is if you look
at this carefully the linearization
order so maybe go back a bit so to enq
an item
the first thing you do is you store the
item in the array and then you increment
the tail uh uh
counter uh
the when does the change become visible
well it doesn't become visible when you
store the item in the array because
nobody cares what's in an item that's uh
not between the head and the tail you
know that could be anything but when you
increment the tail pointer that's when
that change becomes visible that's the
instant when this NQ
happens and similarly for the DQ so the
linearization order is the order in
which the heads and head and tail
pointers are
modified and in fact this works even if
the Plus+ isn't
Atomic as long as the right of the new
value is atomic this works and this is
something again uh you you know if
somebody comes along and uh Demands a
payment uh for something like this then
you might want to check it fairly
carefully but but uh in this case it's
simple enough I think you can trust your
your
intuition
but often when you're dealing with uh
weight free or lock free or clever Kinds
of Kinds of locking you can identify a
point in the program and say this is
where the change takes effect and this
is the linearization point other cases
are more subtle where the linearization
point may depend on other uh aspects of
your
environment and again this only if you
want to do this by yourselves remember
this only works for one ncer and one
dcer and in fact
um this this methodology you know you
can get this down to the machine
instruction level you know where one
compare and swap works this is something
that U Tim was talking about where you
can Define data structures where you
make a lot of changes and then finally
you do one final compare and swap which
makes the change visible to to to
everyone
else okay so
um summary about linearizability is the
claim is that this is a uh this is
almost always the correctness property
that you want for concurrent objects and
I'll say a little bit about that almost
uh qualifier uh in a in a minute but the
claim is that we have this intuitive
notion that operations on shared objects
should be Atomic somehow that the uh
they should take a effect
instantaneously and the claim that this
notion of linearizability is a way of
formalizing this uh notion and it has
this nice composability property which
means you can build large systems out of
objects and you can do that by proving
that the objects are linearizable in
isolation by themselves which again is
not something you should take for
granted so the biggest uh and most
popular
um
alternative is um called sequential
consistency and so the idea for behind
sequential consistency this sounds
almost like linearizability but there's
one um uh important difference so it
says we take a concurrent history
H and we extend it to history G by
completing some operations to throwing
away the rest so that g is equivalent to
a legal sequential history
and the trick here is that uh we don't
require that the real-time ordering be
preserved so sequential consistency says
that uh you have to preserve the um
what's called the program order so if I
do an NQ followed by a DQ then those
operations must appear to H have
happened in that
order but if I do an NQ and I wait for a
week and then somebody else does an NQ
it's okay if those nqs are re ordered
even though in real time it's clear that
they happened in one order logically
it's okay for them to happen in
different order Now linearizability does
not allow you you to do this
linearizability says You must respect
real-time order sequential consistency
says you know don't worry about
it and so uh what are the consequences
of
this well the
um well before I talk about the
consequences I mentioned that this is
kind of the gold standard for describing
a memory models for
multiprocessors now the truth is nobody
actually implements sequential
consistency but sequential consistency
is the property they don't
Implement so if you read a manual they
say well this is not sequentially
consistent in fact here are the
different ways in which we we violate
this but this is the standard by which
you know this is 0 Celsius and they're
they're in the minus Zone but uh you
know what often what they say is well
you can get sequentially consistent
Behavior if you write data race fee
programs if you put in uh fences and
barriers and things like that but
everything is expressed in the language
of sequential
consistency now uh let's see some
examples so here going back to our Q
example uh blue thread nq's X blue
thread DQ's y uh and uh here the Red
Thread nq's Y and again this is the
example that we saw before
and uh it's clear this is not
linearizable because uh there's no way I
can get y to be uh to appear earlier in
the
Q and it's not linearizable because if I
want I can't push the NQ of Y any
further back than this and I can't push
the NQ of X any further than this and
they're still ordered but sequential
consistency uh allows you to push the um
uh points beyond the um these boundaries
and this is sequentially
consistent so you could say well is
isn't this a better um property because
it gives the implementers more
freedom uh the the um Q implementor is
free to allow this Behavior under
sequential consistency but not under um
but not under linearizability
and you know you might counter and say
but intuitively is this what you really
expect but uh there's a um a stronger
thing you can say which is sequential
consistency is not
composable so that is I if I take two
objects that are individually
sequentially consistent and I put them
together in a system the result is not
necessarily sequentially
consistent
uh here's an here's an example I have a
fq um I have two fqs I have p and Q uh
the blue thread nq's X on p nq's x on Q
and then DQ's y from
P the Red
Thread nq's y on q nq's y on P and DQ's
X so it's kind and they're they're
overlapped in the way that that I showed
you so let's look at uh the um
restrictions on ordering that sequential
consistency says so this is our history
so if we look at the behavior of P
that's sequentially
consistent because I can order it in
this order which is clearly a um correct
um U history and we didn't reorder any
of the operations that were done by a
single
thread uh it's also true that Q is
sequentially
consistent because I didn't reorder the
red operations I just reordered the blue
op operations by uh by quite a
bit so this is the ordering that p uh
imposes so P says uh the NQ of Y has to
precede the NQ of x uh which precedes
the DQ of
Y so that's a five4 ordering so that
that's uh that's perfectly okay and then
Q says well the NQ of X has to precede
the NQ of Y and the DQ of x so that's
also perfectly okay uh but when I put
these orders together you'll see that uh
we have a
cycle so each individual object is
sequentially consistent but there's no
way I can take this entire history
consisting of two
objects and uh and reorder things in a
way that respects program order that
gives you a a sequential
execution so this means that I cannot uh
take a system consisting of two
sequentially consistent cues and break
them down
and uh send each one off to be
implemented independently and be sure
that when I bring get them back I can
compose
them so despite the fact that sequential
consistency seems like an intuitively
appealing approach and despite the fact
that it's popular among architects who
don't typically worry much about
composability it for if you're writing
big software programs this is a huge um
limitation the fact that you can't
reason about your components in
isolation
so I think we're approaching a break let
me okay so I'll I'll conclude with with
uh one more point before we give you a u
a break so as I mentioned before most
Hardware architectures don't support
sequential consistency because they
think it's too strong so I've just
finished telling you why it's too weak
and uh the hardware people think it's
too strong uh well well they have they
have some pretty good reasons for that
for that so
um there's something called the flag
principle which is the basis for most
software uh Mutual exclusion algorithms
which is if if I write my variable in
read yours and you write your variable
and read mine one of us will see that
the other is
written and this is you know the the
principle behind every software Mutual
exclusion algorithm ever invented so
that says up here is X write blue writes
one tox y writes one to X each one reads
the other and uh here even though they
both wrote one uh they both read zero so
this is not sequentially consistent or
or linearizable and it's probably not
what you
expected although again this is a case
where each uh individual view is
sequentially consistent but the
composition
isn't uh and you can say well well uh I
would never buy a processor that
displayed this kind of behavior because
it's just wrong but in fact every
processor you can buy has this kind of
behavior and here's why you might say
it's wrong well this pattern is the F
principle that uh uh I talk about in
other
lectures for Mutual for all these Mutual
exclusion algorithms and how can you
build an operating system without Mutual
exclusion uh the other ways say well you
know this is really really expensive to
try to implement
this that uh if every read and WR had to
be had to uh uh display this Behavior
then uh you know you wouldn't buy the
processor because it would be too
slow so what everyone does in fact is
they'll say well this flag principle uh
will in fact be violated by default so
that if you don't ask for consistency
then you won't get it because it's too
expensive to uh to provide
but you'll get it if you ask for it and
asking for it is what does this mean
well when it come comes down to the
hardware when you write to memory you
don't really write to memory what you
really do is you write to some uh buffer
writing to memory is more like writing a
letter a paper letter you and dropping
it off in a mailbox that it is actually
writing on a Blackboard and this is
because memory accesses are very slow
compared to processor speeds so instead
what you do is you you you drop the um
your letter in the mailbox and you go
about your business and nobody's
surprised if I Dr if I send a letter to
my uh to my mom drop it in the mailbox
and then call her up and she hasn't
received the letter then uh you know you
expect that sort of thing and this is
the way modern memory year
works so you want to read a memory
location you loaded into a cache you
write a memory location you update the
cache copy and you kind of lazily write
it back and a processor connects you
lots and lots of
instructions in this iteration and if
you want to make sure that uh a right
that you made has actually taken effect
then you would have it's like uh mailing
a letter and sitting in your closet
until that letter is delivered you know
you probably don't want to do things
that way so the argument is to say that
this violation of the flag principle is
really is what you want most of the time
because you don't want to for to have to
wait for every right to take effect and
only in special cases where you're doing
some kind of synchronization algorithm
uh you have to ask for um you have to
announce that you want uh this kind of
synchronization and then you pay for it
uh when you need
it and this is usually called a memory
barrier or a fence instruction and so if
you do a write and you want to make
absolutely sure that's visible then you
do a
barrier and that's very expensive and
slow and so you only do it when you need
it but if you need it you can do
it and often uh compilers will insert
these things in code for you so you're
usually not uh don't notice
it and um since this is of course on
Java I'll skip that so uh to summarize
real world uh Hardware memory is weaker
than sequential consistency but you can
get sequential consistency and in fact
even linearizability if you're willing
to pay for it which means that you need
to understand when you need it and when
you don't need it and often compilers
can figure this out for you but
sometimes you need to do it
yourself and uh so in the end if you're
talking about uh if you're
reading uh Intel memory manuals then you
need to understand about sequential cons
consistency but if you're writing
software programs then you probably want
to use linearizability as your um
condition okay let's take a five- minute
break and then uh we'll move on to the
next
one so
um I promise you that all of these this
um formalism and
um Theory like reasoning uh wasn't being
done for its own sake it was being done
because we're interested in more
practical problems of how to build
concurrent objects and so now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to try to red
that promise and talk about different
ways of implementing concurrent objects
now that we know that what we wanted to
implement is or linearizable objects you
see if I hadn't told you about
linearizability
then you wouldn't know what it is we're
trying to
implement if I hadn't Justified why
linearizability is a good property you
wouldn't understand why we would be
making such an effort to prove
linearizability but at this point I hope
that you agree with me that uh
linearizability is is the property that
we want to prove and that this is uh the
uh the right kind of exercise that we
should be
pursuing
so um this is part of a larger course
where the course before we talked about
how to implement a spin locks and I'm
not going to talk about that uh here uh
other than to say that uh when we talked
about the lock based queue what we were
really talking about is something where
we have a a lock we have the critical
section which is the code that's being
protected and then when the thread
leaves it releases a lock releases the
lock and uh what we talked about in the
previous lecture was how to implement
these things in an efficient
way um but now I'm going to talk about
something higher level which is uh what
you want to do with these kind of
structures now the main goal that we
want uh which again might seem
obvious uh but actually isn't is that if
we take a computation and we add more
threads then things should not get
worse so if I have one thread that's
using a fq and it takes a certain amount
of time then uh why would I ever have
more than one thread well because I
think I can do things faster so if
adding two threads to a computation
makes it slower then clearly we're in
the wrong um moving in the wrong
direction and uh what we would what we
studied when we talked
about uh the in the Q lock lecture which
I'm not doing is how to build locks that
have this scalability property so you
can say well if we can build locks that
are scalable uh why uh doesn't that mean
we can build any kind of object simply
by using uh scalable
locks and the answer is no because
really what we want when we add more
threads is we want to increase the
throughput we want to get more work done
in the same amount of time because
otherwi otherwise if that wasn't true
why would I buy a multiprocessor to
begin with if it didn't provide some
kind of improved
performance and so the question is so
what kinds of things are
parallelizable and if what we're looking
at is inherently
sequential then in some sense there's no
point in uh look using multicores and
using multiprocessors because we'll
never do better than a single
core uh but it turns out that uh the
situation is actually not uh so bad
because really surprising things are
parallelizable things that might seem
intuitively to be inherently sequential
can be parallelized in certain ways and
we'll look at some of those uh things um
as as we uh as we go
along so um but first i'm going to talk
about
different techniques different patterns
for writing concurrent objects so the
most obvious one is the one that we
looked at with our lock based AQ which
is a course grain synchronization and
that is uh every method locks the object
execute sequential code the releases the
lock and goes on and then goes about its
business and given that uh we know how
to build um you know very efficient
scalable
locks uh you could say will this will uh
you know the scalable locks will help us
to avoid contention and everything works
well and this has the Advantage which uh
should not be discounted that it's uh
fairly easy to get this right in the
sense that if your sequential code is
correct and you put a lock around it
then uh ignoring certain subtleties uh
the your code is probably likely to be
correct which if you're a big company uh
that you know could be very important
because you don't want to be issuing a
buggy a code or spending a lot of money
on Clever
programmers uh
so the rhetorical question are we done
obviously we're not done because it's
only
4:30 the problem of course with this is
the sequential bottleneck where all the
threads have to stand in line and they
only get uh to execute these object
these uh methods one at a time adding
more threads uh won't improve throughput
and we'll have to struggle to keep
things from getting worse
so we need to uh look at things that are
inherently a parallel so what I'm going
to do in this lecture is I'm going to
talk about four different patterns for
writing concurrent objects concurrent
linearizable
objects and
um the goal here is we want to structure
things so that adding threads gives us
more
throughput and of course this will only
work up to a point uh you know you you
saw um Tim's slides where uh you can by
throwing more um threads at a problem uh
you get your througho goes up to some
point when you start saturating
resources but our goal is to push that
out as far as
possible know it's a little bit like
going to the gym you know you want to
push the uh um push things out as far as
they'll go so the first um pattern that
we'll look at is called fine grain
synchronization so this is a very simple
idea the if put one lock on the entire
object then there's no possibility of
concurrency so let's break the lock up
into little pieces so or rather break
the object up into pieces and put a lock
on each piece and this has the property
that if two threads uh touch disjoint
parts of the object then they don't need
to to conflict with one with one another
and so this is a uh fairly uh appealing
approach because it says that uh two
threads will only only conflict if they
happen to uh touch the same part of the
object at the same time and if we break
up the object up up into enough small
pieces we can make that uh relatively
unlikely so the second uh
approach is called optimistic
synchronization so here the idea is that
most of the time with most shared data
structures what you're doing is you're
searching through the data structure
looking for
something and uh if you you acquire
locks while you're searching the object
uh that could be a lot of locks that
could be kind of cumbersome so what
we're going to do is we're going to
search the object without locking it
which is very efficient but dangerous
because while we're searching it other
threads could be changing things out
from underneath you so if you find what
you're looking for then you can't be
sure that it will still be that it's
really there because somebody could
snatch it away from you then you lock
the part of the object that you care
about and then you validate that what
you think you saw is actually there and
then you uh uh go about your business
and if you discover that in fact uh what
you thought you saw isn't what's really
there that is if somebody modified
something um uh after you read it or
remov removed what you're looking for
then you start over again and this is
called optimistic because if there is in
fact no conflict then this is much more
efficient than doing things in a uh
responsible way and if your optimism was
place then it's more expensive because
you have to go and start all over again
so optimistic approaches work well when
contention is fairly low they don't work
so well when there is a lot of
contention uh the next approach is
called lazy
synchronization and I always hate to use
this term when talking to my students
because I'm always urging them to be
industrious so I hate to admit that
being lazy has its uh advantages but
here the idea is that often
with data structures we're either adding
something to the data structure looking
for something or removing
something and the hardest part is almost
always removing
things uh because uh often when you
remove things you have to change uh all
kinds of other um um uh structures and
so the one way to do this is instead of
physically removing something from a
data structure you set a bit marking it
saying this is logically removed if you
see this ignore it and then later when
it's more convenient you can do the
physical removal with all of the work
that's uh that's
required and uh we this idea of
splitting operations into a logical part
where we kind of inefficiently Mark
something as being done but don't
actually do it and the physical part
where we actually do it uh turns out to
be a very effective way of Designing
concurrent data
structures and the final um approach is
to take this notion of fine grain
synchronization to its logical extreme
and reduce all the synchronization to a
single Atomic machine instruction in
this case we'll use something called a
compare and swap uh or or compare and
Set uh which I'll explain later
on so uh the advantage is that uh
compare and
set is a very robust in the sense that
it makes no assumptions all about the
scheduler so if you acquire a lock and
then you take a page fault and you go on
vacation for a long time then other
threads will be locked out of using the
resource but if you the only thing you
do are Atomic machine instructions for
synchronization then it doesn't matter
if the scheduler uh delays you
arbitrarily uh because other threads
will still be able to make progress uh
the disadvantage is that is complex and
sometimes the overhead can be high so uh
this is an idea that works really well
under some circumstances and uh really
badly under other circumstan ances but
it's still a useful thing to know how to
do so in order to uh illustrate these
ideas in a uh specific and yet simple
way I'm going to talk about uh how to do
this on a simple link list data
structure uh later on uh in my my next
lecture we'll talk about some much more
clever data structures but here we just
look at link lists because once you
understand link lists then understanding
things like skip lists and so on will be
much uh
easier and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to build a very simple set
abstraction on top of a linked
list so a set is just an unordered
collection of items uh no
duplicates uh you can add something
remove something and search for
something so this is a very simple um uh
abstraction you could imagine other
methods uh but we won won't um bother
with that uh
here um technically we have we'll do
this as an interface you can add an item
to a set adding an item gives you back a
Boolean if the item was already there
then it didn't modify it and returns
false if it wasn't there then it
modifies it and returns true and so in
each case we return a Boolean telling
you whether the object was modified
except contains the Boolean tells you
whether the object whether the U item
was
there uh being a list we need it has to
be a list of something so we'll have a
list node uh we'll have uh the item of
interest uh we'll have a key which we'll
use to order the items which is usually
just the hash code of the um of the
item and then we'll have a reference to
the next node so this is um exactly what
you would expect it to
be and so what we'll um we we represent
this is we'll have Sentinels on either
end will have the uh you know the
smallest possible and largest possible
value uh these keys will never be uh
searched for added or
removed and these are useful because it
gives us a way of avoiding certain U
boundary
conditions um when we reason about these
things we're going to think in terms of
invariance so the difficulty of
reasoning about these concurrent objects
particularly when we have fine grain
synchronization is that a lot of things
are happening at once and there's a huge
number of possible
interleavings and we can't possibly uh
enumerate all these interleavings so
instead we focus on properties that
remain true no matter how these Atomic
steps are
interleaved um there's a kind of
inductive argument uh because we'll
guarantee that the um invariant is true
when the object is created and we will
show that uh it's um preserved not just
by each method but by each Atomic step
of each
method so and specifically we'll be
looking at the invariance preserved by
the three methods and uh what happens is
almost always when we look at these
things the variant are
trivial and typically in each method
there's one step where proving that the
invariant is preserved is non-trivial
and that's almost always the
linearization point
because that's when something
happens uh technical Point uh invariance
only makes sense if the methods that
we're looking at are the only ones that
are accessing the accessing the object
so for example in C++ any program can
add 27 to a pointer and then store into
it and cause all kinds of um you know
random uh damage we're going to assume
that doesn't happen we're going to
assume that we know exactly uh who is
authorized to modify data structure and
this is easy in a language like Java or
C uh impossible in language like uh
C++ uh the uh interferent one another
subtle point is that this freedom from
interference the idea that our methods
are the only ones accessing the data uh
has to be true for the entire lifetime
of the object of the nodes so when we
talk some of our uh more sophisticated
uh methods we will actually be
traversing nodes after they've been
removed from the
list and so we have to be careful that
when I we remove a node from the list
for example we can't free it return its
storage to the operating system because
somebody might still be using it and in
the garbage collected a language like
Java this is not a problem but in uh
language like C or C++ you have to be
very careful so this is just a warning
that uh there are subtleties hiding in
some of the things that I'll be telling
you okay um what does it mean when I say
I'm using a list to represent a uh a set
well we can break it up into two pieces
there's a concrete representation which
in this case is a list and we have an
abstract rep uh type which is is just a
set and the correspondence between these
things is given by an abstraction map
which says that this list corresponds to
this
set so again this is exactly what uh you
would expect uh to to see uh there's
another issue which is not every list is
a legitimate representation for a set
the way we're going to do this so we're
going to have something called a
representation invariant which tells us
which concrete values are meaningful uh
for example is the list sorted and can
the list contain
duplicates uh the representation
invariant is a uh it's an invariant that
is preserved by each of the methods but
it's also relied on by each of the
methods let me give you a
um a simple
example suppose the ad method leaves
behind two copies of X and remove
removes only
one so uh pretty clearly this is a wrong
uh the implementation is wrong because
remove is supposed to remove the value
from the set completely and the question
is uh do I fire the person who wrote the
ad method or do I fire the person who
wrote did the remove
method and the answer is it depends on
what your repent variant was if your
repon variant said no duplicates then
add was wrong if the repon variant said
duplicates are okay then remove is
wrong so uh the notion of the
representation invariant in some sense
is necessary in order to uh be able to
glue these different implementations
together and have them work
correctly so the rep variant says no
duplicates add is incorrect otherwise
remove uh so um our repid variant is
going to be uh that uh the
hail Sentinel node is always reachable
from the head uh list is always going to
be sorted
and there'll be will be no
duplicates and those are the uh we're
going to guarantee that's true when we
create it we're going to guarantee that
every individual step of every operation
including ones that modify the list
preserve these
invariants and the abstraction map is uh
given a list uh it's a set of items that
are basically reachable from the head
we're going to change this a bit later
on
yeah
so so the the reason we're choosing to
sort it is because when we're searching
with something we can quit early if we
see that it's
sorted but but it's not necessary we we
I I could have said well we don't care
if it's sorted and then just made sure
that when you search something you go
all the way to the end so these the
decision of what invariant you want to
use is kind of it's an engineering
decision but it just has to be
unambiguous
so um it's clear how you would do add
and remove in a sequential um
set if I want to add something I um
basically you know string it in if I
want to remove something I take the uh
reference to the next one and I send it
to the one after that so this is how you
do it in sequential
code uh course grain locking we put a
single lock on the head and every method
call acquires that
lock so here I want to put something on
the green thread acquires the lock
turning it green uh and does its uh does
its work uh the disadvantage of course
is that this is uh sequential all the
threads have to stand in line and your
throughput is going to uh not uh work
well so if if you don't have much
contention then you should uh do it this
way because it's simple but if you have
any contention at all then you should
think about something a little bit more
um uh
clever uh plus you'll get a contention
on the
lock okay so
um summarize course grade methods uh
it's easy because you just take
sequential code which is presumably easy
to write you put a lock around it and uh
and you're done uh it's simple and uh
easy to show that is correct uh and
sometimes that's what you want but uh it
uh Works poorly with the contention and
it's not really
scalable so the alternative is to look
at fine grain
locking and the thing about fine grain
locking is that uh it looks easy but it
can be kind of
deceptive that uh it's possible that
there are subtle locks subtle
bugs and so I'm going to describe a way
of doing uh fine grain locking on this
list and who knows I might try to fool
you and tell you something that's not
correct so if you see anything that sets
your Spider Sense tingling you know then
uh you know feel free to ask me about
the qu ask me about it and I will
probably be evasive because I'm uh you
know still trying to to fool you a
little
bit so the idea as you said before is
you break the object into pieces you put
a lock on each piece and uh as long as
uh your methods are working on disjoint
pieces then uh you can then then you
don't have any
conflict so the simplest way to do this
in our list is something called hand
overhand
locking uh for reasons that will become
clear so the idea here is that the green
thread comes along and it
locks The
Sentinel
and as it goes along now we're instead
of having one lock on the entire object
we're to put a lock on each um
node and so the green thread as it moves
along will lock the next object and now
it's going to release the lock on the
first one and acquire the lock on the
next one so it's called hand overhand
locking because it's always holding one
lock but it's holding a lock it acquires
the next one releases the first and then
locks the second
one and as you can see this uh allows
for some you know for more
concurrency so here the green thread
wants to
remove uh
B it locks The Sentinel says that's
that's not B it locks the next one and
says uh that's not B it releases the
lock on the Sentinel and then it locks
the node uh
B and then it um swings the pointer
around and then releases its
locks and it's
done
yeah ah so so there is so so so no
nobody's going to delete the Sentinal uh
because our convention is that you can't
do that but it's true that you could
delete uh intermediate
nodes and so our rule though is that
um that we have to
lock nodes as we visit them and I think
you're correct that uh we should be
suspicious of what happens uh with the
hand overhand locking while while leads
are going on and I I will say more about
that in a
minute so let's look at uh what happens
when we have concurrent
removes concurrent
delions so here the Red Thread uh starts
out and it uh oh here we um I'm
addressing the question of why we need
two locks instead of
one and so what happens here is we have
the green thread comes along it wants to
remove
B and here they're only holding one
lock and as you can see if you're only
holding one lock then uh bad things can
happen so here C wasn't
removed
so the problem here is that uh if we
want to delete a particular node C then
we need to take uh B's next node and
next pointer and and swing it
around but the problem is that somebody
uh deleting
B while we're working on B somebody
could uh be deleting it uh as
well so the danger as I think
uh uh one of the people in the class
aspected is that if you're not careful
the uh someone could delete something
while you're working on it so in fact
the Insight here is
that if you're deleting a node even
though you're not modifying that node
you're modifying its neighbor you have
to lock the node being
deleted so that says that you sometimes
you have to lock a node even if you're
not going to modify
it so the key Insight here is that if a
node is locked then you nobody can
delete the nobody else can delete the
node
successor so if a thread locks both the
node to be deleted and its predecessor
then we can avoid that
bug so locking a node not only uh you
don't lock a node only because you want
to modify it you also lock a node
because you want to prevent someone else
from modifying it and this is a uh a
subtle point and uh the source of much
anguish if you give it in a uh final
exam
so let's look at uh hand overhand
locking again so now we have um GRE
three wants to remove
B so it finds the
B it while holding the lock for B it uh
uh redirects the uh next uh reference of
a around and then uh then we're done so
now let's go back to the danger
Dangerous situation that we looked at
before where we got ourselves into
trouble and and so here what happens is
the threads the green thread is chasing
the Red Thread so the Red Thread is
doing the hand overhand locking uh
business and so now what happens what
happened before was that uh the red
thread the green thread managed to
delete the node out from underneath the
Red Thread but now the Red Thread is
holding both locks both the uh the lock
for the node that is being deleted and
the lock for the predecessor of that
node and the green node is frustrated
because it can't go ahead and do any
damage so it can't acquire the node the
lock it's waiting waiting um the red
node removes C it goes on and then the
green node proceeds and then things work
correctly so the U subtle Point here was
that uh you have to unlock the node that
you're deleting as well as the node that
you're modifying in order for this to to
work
now I should mention that
um you know just you know this is this
code is
correct but um you shouldn't take my
word for it I mean you can take my word
for it now because we don't have time to
do a of formal proof but as you can see
there are a lot of subtleties here and
uh you know you can become very good at
reasoning about these programs to the
point where you can look at the code and
instantly say something seems wrong here
and fish out the bug but this is not a
uh an ability you're necessarily born
with it's something that comes with a
practice and so uh when you're dealing
with these kinds of things at least at
the beginning don't trust your intuition
when you when you think that something
looks uh correct so uh what does this
look like when we do code uh
you I want to remove something I get the
key I'm looking at two nodes at a time
the predecessor and the current node and
uh the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to make sure that these are
are uh these two locks are released when
I return by putting them in a finally
Clause this is a bit of java um lore and
then I do everything else in the middle
uh what is that well in this
case I'm going to uh lock I'm going to
get the predecessor and lock it at the
beginning and then I'm going to get the
next node and lock it and then as I go
through I'm going the invariant at the
top of the loop is that I've got I
acquired the lock for both of
these and I'm going to Traverse the list
so here I'm going to search the key
range at the start of each Loop both the
predecessor and current nodes are locked
and I'm going to change that as I go
through the loop if the item is found
then I'm going to remove
it uh if not I'm going to unlock the
predecessor at this point only one node
is unlocked so I've temporarily violated
uh my Loop inv variant I'm going to
demote the predecessor the current to
the predecessor I'll find and lock the
new current and then when I go back to
the top I've got the predecessor and
current both uh both
locked and if I go all the way through
and I don't find it then I return
false and so uh question is well why is
this linearizable well the first thing
that we want to check is that our uh
invariance hold that we haven't broken
any of the variants so the claim is at
this point the predecessor is reach
reachable from the head head uh the
current node is the successor to the
predecessor and that implies that the
current no node is in is
reachable and we need to worry about
reachability because we're worried that
another thread will delete the node out
from uh from underneath
us so if the item is present then this
is linearization
point you know it's the point where we
uh where we find this uh this
item
and then the thing that you want to
check is that because the node is locked
no other node can remove it which means
to say that it that it remains
reachable
uh a subtle Point here is that if the
item is is present then the
linearization point is fairly easy to
see but what if the item isn't
there so the linearization point if the
item isn't there is the moment the
process learns that the item isn't there
because that's when the uh its absence
becomes visible and uh identifying this
sort of thing is a little bit more
subtle because we need to check that our
invariance uh still uh still
hold and in fact uh if it's not there
then the uh linearization point is as
soon as the current has a key that's
larger than the key that we're looking
for then at that point it's uh
irrevocable that uh the item is absent
because before that point some other
thread could insert the item that we're
looking for in front of us and then we
would then we would find
it uh to for adding uh it's the same
sort of thing we have to lock the
predecessor and the successor even
though we're not modifying the successor
uh why well because things would get
very confusing if somebody deleted the
successor while we were inserting the
node you know that that would be
incorrect Behavior so this is another
case where we need to lock a node even
though we're not modifying
it
um we have the same abstraction map as
before uh checking the repon variant is
uh fairly straightforward most of the
lines of code it's trivial the places
where it isn't trivial are the
linearization points and there it's not
too hard this isn't of course on formal
methods I'm not going to go over how to
do that in practice you should be able
to look at this and informally scratch
your head and convince yourself that it
works and uh that's uh good enough most
of the
time okay from an engineering point of
view this is better than a COR grain
lock uh because now we can have more
than one thread traversing the que at
the same time it's still far from ideal
because we're doing a lot of lock
acquisition and releases
and despite what I said about lock
acquisition and releases uh being
scalable if you're using sufficiently
clever locks it's still going to be
expensive because lock acquisition and
releases turn into Atomic compare and
swap operations which are uh which do uh
nasty things to your U memory hierarchy
so we would really like to avoid doing
so many um
locks so the next one I'm going to look
at is optimistic
synchronization
where the idea is we're going to find
the noes without
locking uh which is much more
efficient um but it's dangerous because
uh you can't be sure that anything you
see is actually there so then we'll find
the node that we think we want then
we'll lock it and then we'll
check
yes no we're on the locking two nodes at
a time at most two
nodes yeah yeah there there's no
overtaking so so so so one more
disadvantage is is if one thread is
halfway through and it falls asleep then
nobody else can overtake it then they
they'll queue up so so there is
concurrency there but limited a
concurrency so here we are traversing
the list without locking and as you can
see it's much faster than when we uh
when we acquired
locks then we want to add C which go of
course goes between b and d and green
red says oh great this is uh where I'm
going to put these things so it locks
both
nodes and then it insert
C and uh you know this is uh much um
more attractive than going through and
doing the hand overhand locking business
because we only acquire two locks so the
number of locks we acquire is
constant and uh we're done what you know
what could possibly go wrong with this
uh with this
approach oh uh lots and lots of things
can go wrong you know the things that
you suggested are is only the beginning
of what can go wrong with
this so what what can go wrong is we'll
roll back the film to uh this point
where green is about to uh acquire the
locks and now it goes to sleep and red
comes along and decides to remove
B and it acquires its
locks it redirects the
pointer and it goes away and now green
wakes up acquires its locks and adds a c
but of course C isn't really in the
list so that's one thing that could
could go wrong with
this so we need to uh to fix that so the
way we do this is after we acquired the
lock we need to validate what we
saw so it's not enough just to look at
the nodes that we've locked to make sure
that uh there we saw what we expect we
need to look at a wider context to make
sure that everything works
so what we need to do is we need to make
sure that b is still reach after we lock
b we need to check that it's still
reachable from the
head so what we're going to do is going
to ret Traverse the list and say yep B
is uh B is
reachable so can anything else go wrong
well once you lock something nobody can
delete it and so if I lock something and
then I check it's still reachable then
it will remain reachable that's that
that requires proof you know that that
isn't an obvious property but but it
it's true in this case so that you see
something that's in the list you lock it
and once it's locked it may be that that
it is deleted from the list but while
you're holding the lock if it's
reachable then it will stay
reachable but the other way you can get
yourself into
trouble is that after I
lock uh or before I lock these
nodes another threed comes along and
adds something in between it adds B
Prime between B and
C and then what happens is when it's
done um the green thread wakes up
acquires the locks and
inadvertently
um uh deletes it by adding C so that is
another way you can get into a trouble
with this optimistic scheme so the
second part of the validation is we need
to check that b still points to the
seat and so uh the linearization point
is in fact when you um you know when you
release the
locks uh given that the validation
succeeded uh we have the same
abstraction
map uh notice that we do we might
reverse a deleted nodes so you can't
when you remove a node from the list you
can allow it to be garbage collected but
you can't explicitly uh return it return
the storage to the um to the memory I'm
going to skip over the
um correctness conditions I'll just show
you the uh the validation
here uh with the validation validation
code does this is the validate you take
the predecessor and current nodes which
you've locked you begin to the beginning
you search the range you see if the uh
if it's reachable then you're then
you're happy uh otherwise if the
predecessor is not reachable you
um you return false
yes oh uh yeah I'm not claiming that the
performance of this is really any good
so I've been careful uh to focus here on
correctness what I'm going to do in the
next one is show you how to make this
uh how to change this to a lazy list
which where the performance is actually
plausible so I've been doing a little
bit of hand is quicker than the I here
um because in fact each of the
improvements I've suggested up up till
now will probably make performance worse
so I I don't want to misrepresent that
but I'm willing to obscure it a little
bit for dramatic
effect so uh let's see given that where
uh I'm going to move ahead a little
bit
yeah so
um anyway the the rest of it is just
details of how this works showing you
that the cartoons can be translated into
Java uh you can I'm sure you can figure
that out um for yourselves what I'm
going to do is I'm going to focus here
on the good and bad aspects of this
design and this is I'm out of time in my
next lecture I'll resume and tell you
the other patterns you know the the lazy
and the lock free approaches to um
designing this thing so the
um really good thing about this is that
they're limited hotspots where Hots spot
is a for example a lock that gets a lot
of contention because you're traversing
the list without H actually modifying
anything uh your um throughput is higher
because there's no
interference the uh interestingly the
traversals here are weight free meaning
that uh I can go through and if I'm
delayed in the middle of a traversal
that's not going to bother anyone
else and uh later on we'll talk about
making more of the operations be uh be
weight
free uh the
um good thing about this is that instead
of acquiring an average of uh you know
n/ two uh locks we only acquire
two uh this is good for performance and
it's good for concurrency uh the uh
problem with this is that we need to
Traverse the list
twice because the validation is really
expensive and the contains method the
one that where we search for an object
uh acquires locks now the folklore is
that for any kind of shared data
structure uh 90% of the operations are
searches are read only searches uh 9%
are ads and 1%
removes and uh you know this may vary a
little bit from application to
application but this is pretty much a
rule of thumb that you can use and so if
we could figure out a way to remove
locks from the contains method then that
would have a huge impact on the
Practical
performance of this um of this data
structure so uh this optimistic approach
is effective if the cost of scanning
twice without locks is less than the
cost of scanning once with locks
which is probably true but um you know
perhaps not ideal uh the we don't like
the fact that contains acquires locks
because it's often um you know very um
you know the most common operation and
we don't really care that much if add
and remove need to acquire expensive
locks because they're rarer but uh it's
a common wisdom that you want to
optimize the uh the most common case and
not bother optimizing the less common
case so what I'll talk about next time
is uh the lazy list which is like the
optimistic except we only scan once
we're not going to have to do that
repeated scan for
validation and contains will be will be
weight free it will not need to acquire
any
locks and the key Insight is that our
problem is really that we're moving
locks deleting things causes problems
all of the bugs that I showed you had to
do with the deletes so deletes are
dangerous and I'm going to tell you how
to diffuse this by uh doing deletions in
a lazy two-stage way which sounds like a
technical trick but it's actually
extremely useful in a a large number of
situations okay so I'll um get to that I
guess on
Thursday